you're the best friend I've ever had I'm
sorry for everything we don't know how
to feel anymore Justin Alex you guys
used to be our favorite couple but now
things are just different
sure Bryce and Monty committed
horrendous acts but they didn't deserve
what happened to them you're lucky your
father is the deputy Alex because any
other police squad would have gotten to
the bottom of things
deputy sandal might be okay with burning
the evidence but we want some answers
there are example of loose ends that
need tying you're watching ten
unanswered questions from season three
of 13 reasons why it would be a terrible
thing to blame the wrong person from
Bryce's murder why was everyone mad at
Zac for calling the cops
at the end of season two Tyler was ready
to launch a full-blown attack on the
students of Liberty High clays first
instinct was to approach Tyler and talk
him down
whereas axe was to call the cops which
is what you're supposed to do in times
of crises Zack was right to want to
report Tyler who was unsteady and
dangerous but the entire group gave him
a hard time about it the gang was angry
with Zack for calling the police which
was more than a little shocking
why didn't sac go to jail we never
suspected Alex of killing Bryce because
of Bryce's strength and size Zack was
truly the only person who could take
Bryce down and he did just that he broke
his arms and legs leaving him completely
defenseless which is the only reason
Alex was able to push Bryce into the
water but for some strange reason Zack
managed to escape a jail sentence
deputy sandal relieved Zack of any blame
but he definitely deserved some heat for
beating Bryce senseless did you find it
weird that Zack wasn't punished for his
actions
why did Bryce have a hole in his head
clay was absolutely terrified when he
stumbled across Tyler's disturbing
pictures he was certain that Tyler had
shot Bryce because word on the street
was that a gun had been used in the
murder a large gash could be seen on
Bryce's head which resembled a gunshot
wound but in the end it was proclaimed
that Bryce had passed away from drowning
making us think Tyler was to blame
accounted for some pretty interesting
episodes but it didn't explain the hole
in Bryce's head
why isn't Tyler going to jail Tyler was
given a second chance in season three
which most of us would agree is the
theme of the entire season
Tyler opened up about what Monty did to
him he started his healing process and
began to enjoy his life again
but during Anees confession she told
deputies sandals at the Spring Fling
shooting hadn't been a prank and that
Tyler had been the shooter if you took
Anees entire confession to heart why
didn't he arrest Tyler and question him
why did Dean assault Jessica Rice Walker
was forced to attend a prep school after
the events of season two but fitting in
with the boys proved to be a lot harder
than it used to be how's the adjustment
Dean Holbrook had problems with Bryce
because of his reputation which is why
we thought he'd be the last person to
assault a woman we were shocked when
Dean grabbed Jessica at the football
game and basically started the riot so
why would Dean bully Bryce for
disrespecting women only to act in a
similar manner
why did clay need a fake alibi clay
Johnson was the number one suspect
throughout season 3 the police were
hell-bent on arresting him because he
had sent Rhys some threatening messages
but what really made clay look guilty
was that he didn't have an alibi Ani was
quick to jump in and lie for clay saying
that they were together after the riot
but Clay's whereabouts are still a
mystery
and so are unease did Monty deserve a
second chance
season 3 of 13 reasons why was all about
Redemption we got to see Bryce's side of
things and watched as he slowly began to
turn a new leaf
Tyler was given a second chance and
proved everyone wrong he got better and
healed his emotional wounds but Monty
was never given the chance to get better
he was just starting to embrace his true
self when he got sent to jail did Monty
deserve the chance to prove that he was
more than his actions
how do Winston and Ani know each other
we see Winston approach Ani at the end
of season 3 he tells her that he knows
that she lied and that Monty deserved
better what did you tell the cops
he didn't kill Bryce
he was with me this scene was
interesting because it sort of sets
things up for a potential fourth season
but if there's one thing we don't
understand its how on Ian wins didn't
know each other were you guys asking
yourselves the same question let us know
in the comments how does Tyler feel
about Monty's death Tyler finally found
his voice in season 3 and reported Monty
to the police this resulted in Monty
being arrested and killed in jail on his
very first night
although Tyler wanted justice we're not
so sure he wanted Monty to go the way he
did Tyler seemed happy at the end of
season 3 which made us wonder if he was
affected by Monty's death or not who's
the next villain Brice Monty and Tyler
were the antagonists of seasons 1 2 & 3
but now Tyler is doing better than ever
and Bryce and Monty are no longer in the
picture so if season 4 gets confirmed
who willed a new antagonist be we doubt
Winston could be the bad guy considering
he's proven to have morals what do you
think will happen if season 4 gets
confirmed tell us in the comments give
this video a big thumbs up and subscribe
to the things thanks for watching we'll
catch you later
[Music]